President Biden caught trying to cover
up his failure at the border a damning
new report reveals the White House
pressure the Democrat mayor in El Paso
Texas to not declare an emergency over
fear it would hurt the president's image
unbelievable the mayor came into the
demands even though his city was being
overwhelmed by thousands of migrants and
when they're not covering up the crisis
turns out they're sleeping on the job
perhaps taking a cue from Sleepy Joe
himself the guy who leads the U.S
Customs and Border Protection Agency is
being slammed by his colleagues for
reportedly being disconnected from his
work and sleeping through key meetings
on the migration crisis Greg
what if the meeting was really boring
though no I know I know because you are
you are definitely a sleeper you were I
I walked by on the 21st floor and I've
seen you just completely out while
people are talking I was focused but
think about what a contrast that is so
the guy's in charge is sleeping on the
job and he still has a job meanwhile the
people doing their job which is trying
to keep uh illegal aliens from crossing
the border their entire careers were
ruined they were accused of whipping
migrants so this here's the guy who's
disconnected from the reality and the
people that are living the reality are
getting screwed meanwhile you got my
orcas saying like you know you shouldn't
be reporting on an open border because
that entices Smugglers know you hairless
Gremlin having an open border entices
Smugglers what he's really trying to say
is I wish the media will make just wish
Fox News would stop showing America why
I should be fired because I don't
understand why Majorca is still there
either after what he did to these uh
what he did to the Border agents
hairless Gremlin has to be one of Greg's
all time greatest insults careless
Gremlin do you when when Joe Biden says
that to an El Paso mayor
um what does that tell you about his
leadership a couple things so the
pressuring of the El Paso mayor to not
do something that would make Biden look
bad reminds me of what we learned about
last week which is the White House was
trying to pressure OPEC not to cut oil
production until after the midterms
because it would look bad and so
everything was political even though the
policy is actually hurting the people of
the United States that's not good the
other thing is I learned today from our
very own bill malusian the El Paso mayor
has sent 11 000 migrants to New York
City on buses nobody nobody complains
about the El Paso mayor why Democrats
exactly Abbott has only sent 3 100
migrants to New York City so you see the
disparity there about this guy the
commissioner so
the Republicans warned during his
confirmation that this was going to be a
problem basically you can't have a
sanctuary City's guy yeah running CBP
that's like having a drug dealer run the
drug enforcement agency it doesn't make
any sense and this is what they're
getting tonight so Greg wants running
the DEA Judge Jeanine your take on what
we've heard from Joe Biden and this
sleeper well you know it's like we now
have you know they used to have the
Three Stooges Curly Larry and mo well
now we have Kamala mayorkas and Chris
Chris Magnus being the commissioner
who's sleeping on the job I mean the
crazy part of all this is that they want
people to come in let I mean let's just
admit it they're not trying to stop them
they're not doing anything I I guess
they're they're they're they're just
letting them come in if it weren't for
the drones we wouldn't have known
anything about the Del Rio uh that all
of the thousands coming through Del Rio
and if it weren't for Bill malusian we
wouldn't know anything about this so
they want to hide it from the American
people but in the end I mean they're all
over the place they're going all over
the country and it is about politics
they'll complain about a republican
Governor they'll never complain about a
Democrat mayor sending people into uh
into the like mayor Adams he's so
fixated on Ron DeSantis and fixated on
Greg Abbott and it's sad because people
want to trust their their leaders they
want to trust the people that they voted
for they want to leave them they want to
think they're saying the truth but
they're not they're lying it's all about
ideology and power if you were the chief
of U.S border Patrol how would you
handle it I would let all Brits in
immediately so that we could reclaim our
territory that was so cruelly lost to us
thanks to that incompetent George III
and uh Megan would I support them the
king of Deportes
we are very grateful that you've taken
charge of them um you want to be more
Brave that I suspect Meghan Markle wants
to be Queen of the United States of
America yes
um no look I think the we have a similar
issue with our our border now in the
French Channel and it's the same kind of
arguments as the situation gets worse
and worse particularly on the left there
are a lot of people who simply cover
their eyes fingers in the ears this is
not happening it's not an emergency it's
not a problem so they don't want
anything to really be done about it and
if you try and say anything should be
done automatically you're branded a
racist it's the same thing in America on
a bigger scale you've got many more
people coming over the border illegally
clearly in many parts of that border it
is an emergency but Joe Biden as I
discussed earlier about the color of the
sky he's a guy who doesn't want you to
believe what you see with your own eyes
it's complete delusion so he's saying
there is no emergency please don't save
as an emergency it's bad for me even
when there is one he said as you rightly
pointed out into the Saudis don't cut
all production before the midterms that
will probably have an effect on gas
prices that might hurt me at the
midterms it's all delusion it's all
smoke and mirrors and ultimately I think
the American people I think they can
cope with bad news bit like the Brits
we're a stoic peoples right the the
Americans and the Brits we can cope with
bad news if we believe it's being given
to us honestly this is the situation
this is what we're trying to do to fix
it judge us accordingly but when they
try and tell you it's better than it
actually is and you believe they're
lying to you that I think is a real
problem for integrity and honesty in
public office and I think people will
vote accordingly all right Jesse can I
tell you who I think leaked there's a
story about the CBP Commissioner of
falling asleep in meetings Kamala Harris
take the pressure off the border is old
enough that is you know what you got it
I think I got it that's why we love data
it sleeps on the job she but Greg be
careful hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else